one particularly interesting thing about
observables and observable arrays is
that they're actually functions if we
hop over into the console here I can
verify that this page has knockout by
typing K oh sure enough knockout is this
object if I make a new observable array
I can say K o dot observable array and
inside I'm going to pass it its initial
array sure enough that returns our
observable array now I'm going to go
ahead and make a variable I'll call it
foo and now we can call console dot dur
on foo now before I run this I just want
to point out that this observable array
here foo is a function I can validate
that by typing just simply foo and sure
enough you can see that it's a function
now remember that in JavaScript
functions are also objects and if we
extrapolate from that we can infer that
functions will also be able to have
properties on them let's show that by
typing console derp foo sure enough if
we open this up we can see all of this
stuff on our function now as a side
point this might look familiar
it's very similar to how jQuery works if
we go to jQuery comm inspect element and
go to our console we can type jQuery and
we can see that jQuery is also a
function however if we type console or
jQuery we can see we get this function
with a bunch of stuff inside of it what
this means is we can run jQuery like a
function just like this or we can say
jQuery dot now the same goes for knock
out our observable array we can run it
like this and get the value or we can go
ahead and say foo dot and I'll say push
5 when I push the number 5 into this
array it returns just like push normally
does the total length of the array and
now if I run foo I can get back 1 2 3 5
with 4 of them in there so in this way
knockout and jQuery work similarly
observables and observable
arrays are actually functions with keys
on them as well just like jQuery is a
function with a bunch of keys and
methods on it now many people don't know
this and they use jQuery and knock out
very successfully but it's wonderful to
understand a bit more about what's
actually going on under the hood